Samira López: Today’s focus: accessibility audit fixes.
Jordan Patel: Any blockers from last time?
Jordan Patel: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Riley Chen: I propose we split accessibility audit fixes into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; ship a thin slice.
Samira López: Risk: data migration for accessibility audit fixes.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; parallelize testing.
Jordan Patel: Let’s keep this within this sprint on accessibility audit fixes.
Priya Singh: Risk: flaky tests for accessibility audit fixes.
Priya Singh: From QA perspective, We might need a migration.
Samira López: I propose we split accessibility audit fixes into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: I propose we split accessibility audit fixes into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; start with a spike.
Samira López: We need to timebox the spike on accessibility audit fixes.
Avery Kim: My take is we split accessibility audit fixes into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Let’s keep this within this sprint on accessibility audit fixes.
Avery Kim: Risk: accessibility gaps for accessibility audit fixes.
Samira López: Risk: scope creep for accessibility audit fixes.
Avery Kim: Action: write migration.
Priya Singh: Risk: scope creep for accessibility audit fixes.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: Risk: flaky tests for accessibility audit fixes.
Samira López: Risk: scope creep for accessibility audit fixes.
Avery Kim: I propose we split accessibility audit fixes into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: I think we split accessibility audit fixes into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Action: create test plan.
Riley Chen: We should add a feature flag on accessibility audit fixes.
Priya Singh: From QA perspective, We need to align with capacity.
Samira López: My take is we split accessibility audit fixes into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Risk: accessibility gaps for accessibility audit fixes.
Avery Kim: Observability dashboards for errors on accessibility audit fixes.
Samira López: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; parallelize testing.
Priya Singh: Risk: flaky tests for accessibility audit fixes.
Priya Singh: I propose we split accessibility audit fixes into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Risk: data migration for accessibility audit fixes.
Avery Kim: Risk: data migration for accessibility audit fixes.
Priya Singh: Risk: flaky tests for accessibility audit fixes.
Priya Singh: We should add a feature flag on accessibility audit fixes.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; ship a thin slice.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; parallelize testing.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; ship a thin slice.
Samira López: Action: set up dashboards.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; start with a spike.
Avery Kim: My take is we split accessibility audit fixes into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on accessibility audit fixes; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: Risk: flaky tests for accessibility audit fixes.
Priya Singh: Edge cases around auth and retries on accessibility audit fixes.
Noah Williams: Risk: flaky tests for accessibility audit fixes.
Samira López: UX needs a final pass on accessibility audit fixes.
Jordan Patel: From design side, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Riley Chen: Action: book design review.
Avery Kim: UX needs a final pass on accessibility audit fixes.
Noah Williams: My take is we split accessibility audit fixes into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Risk: accessibility gaps for accessibility audit fixes.
Noah Williams: Infra-wise, Specifically for accessibility audit fixes.
Avery Kim: Okay, who can take ownership?
Priya Singh: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Jordan Patel: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.